[Music]
welcome everybody to the 10 trillion
dollar national we could pay i could
have paid off the national debt
100 i chose to build this nuclear
fallout shelter we're billionaires baby
that's right and and also
reason to celebrate the billionaire
attacks is off the table thank god which
means that me and you will be sitting
pretty in our bunker
and our back suits
i was a little worried at first i was
like oh no is this gonna happen
and then i started posting on twitter
immediately like hey you know once they
start taxing us they'll tax you as well
just kidding that wasn't me that was
elon musk where is that where would this
country be
without billionaires being slightly less
rich you know they're truly oppressed
marginalized community everybody talks
about minorities but the biggest
minority of all 700 billionaires that
we're about to get taxed yeah i mean
that's it's basically an apartheid state
we're living in yeah no literally of of
you know
but like the reverse of that right yeah
um we've got so much to talk about today
oh so hassan just a little in the show
note hassan is out of town
next week yeah i'm doing a twitch rivals
where this is like the first ever one
that they're doing uh since kovid
and uh i'm gonna be engaging in athletic
endeavors really yeah there's like wild
[ __ ] that we're supposed to be doing you
should be doing pretty good i think then
we'll see i mean i got uh i can't reveal
who my teammate is yet but like we'll
see there's some really there's some
really athletic dudes involved like
cipher pk some twitch streamers are like
weirdly fit well yeah because they like
it it depends on how little they stream
if they stream like
four hours like once every couple days
and then they have a lot of time to
themselves to work out like tifu and
[ __ ] i mean in a death match you would
probably win yeah it was like a
free-for-all death match well maybe
maybe tyler won i there's a couple
there's a couple of streamers that i i
was pretty yacked no not t food tyler
won tyler one oh yeah he's scared he's
insane like he's he's the type of dude
who could just like he's short but he's
he's got any crazy energy he i think he
hit like a like a literal deadlift uh uh
record or something
really yeah no he's a studio i i really
respect him i respect everyone that
works out doesn't matter what their
background is doesn't wonder what they
believe in because like
you know that it takes a lot of
dedication so i just i respect them
unconditionally thank you yeah thanks
for saying that about me so much to get
to today
uh the infrastructure bill that was uh
you know meant to be the greatest
legislation since fdr's new deal
uh meant to uplift the uh working-class
people of this country
in a way that we've never seen before
is pretty much dying before we get into
kind of more details about that we do
have some right wing cringe comp
i want to go over
for example
so this one comes to you from rumble
which you know is good rumble the right
wing basically
the twitter for um
you know pedophiles and nazis or
youtubers more youtubers
so denise d'souza who's like a [ __ ] bag
[ __ ] the only man to go to prison
for uh for for campaign finance
violations in a country like america
where
it's literally legal to bribe elected
officials
with contributions this [ __ ] dumbass
did like straw donations
and like actually went to jail for it
yeah and people love him too but you
know with spicy takes like this who
could it so during the during the right
after the election he says next time
someone asks for proof of voter fraud
show them that before you start fun fact
about dinesh d'souza
used to date laurie ingram
really i think so or was it ann coulter
[ __ ] they're i'm being
you know
that's a big difference and i hate to
say that but i feel like
no no
i know for a fact that laura ingram
worked with dinesh d'souza in the
college paper when they were both in
colombia i'm just saying ann coulter and
laura ingram big difference
yeah no i know big difference well i
think it was laura ingram though uh
no it looks like it was ann coulter
unless he dated both and coulter makes
sense she
dated uh conservative writer dinesh
d'souza according to her wikipedia oh no
they dated nope he dated both did he
really
dated vogue this guy is the
controversial
playboy what a legend
this guy is this guy is red pill he lays
pipe he lays pogba you can see
oh gosh
so anyway here oh shredder you're here
hi shredder hello
welcome
the revolution is starting now shredder
anyway
so here is the great thinker next time
someone asks for proof of voter fraud
show them this so let's watch this now
one of those cases involve a woman who
died in 2017 the itunes david charns
looking into that and david you talked
to this woman's husband kirk cartel's
wife rose marie who passed away three
years ago she is one of two cases of
somebody who died on clark county's
voter rolls they were sent a mail in
ballot and that ballot was returned the
question now is though who voted for her
it was uh disbelief
just
it made no sense to me kurt cartel said
he was surprised when he found out his
wife who died in 2017 had sent in a
mail-in ballot i was surprised because
she passed away three years ago i was
surprised to even get that rosemary
hartle died at 52 from breast cancer her
name is still on clark county's voter
worms
horrific somebody
cast a ballot and since everyone in
those roles got a ballot one was sent to
rose marie but kirk says a ballot never
got to his house that is pretty
sickening to me to be honest with you
according to balatrax the mail-in ballot
was sent october 9 and returned the day
before election day clark county
officials say rosemarie's signature is a
match to what's on their records
registrar for elections joe gloria says
any illegal activity will be flagged now
this is disgusting so what happened
actually so what happened because like
there's no shot this is where the story
ends so what happened
was that uh it was him
he's the one
that voted for his wife and he's [ __ ]
got arrested let's go
yeah brave so what do you mean brother
he had to do it was apparently he voted
for his dead wife and so far this is
what i believe the only case of uh voter
fraud basically
in nevada yeah in nevada
this is the one case that everybody was
hyped about saying like proof of voter
fraud yeah he voted for his dead wife
and now he was arrested
uh let's see you know what's funny last
week the state's democratic attorney
general working with nevada's republican
secretary of state announced that
investigators had cracked the case
the man himself was charged with two
counts of fraud voting more than once in
the same election voting using another
person's name he forged his late wife's
signature to cast the ballot she'd been
sent
and he's uh been charged for of felonies
each punishable by a prison term of four
years and a fine of five thousand so you
know summary
you know he's gonna have like a coveted
lawyer [ __ ] you know one of those
like q and on lawyers like come in and
they'll go fund me like a million yeah
yeah yeah he's he was falsely accused i
love that i love that he could have just
like he could have gotten away with it
very likely if he just like shut the
[ __ ] up about it but he had to go to the
local news and be like who's doing this
the best part
the best part
read this title again by denise the
great thinker next time someone asks for
proof for voter fraud show them this how
true it is yeah so how true it is so
there is i don't know if you if you know
this or not but like there is no
empirical evidence
that shows that voter fraud is rampant
numerous investigations have been
conducted by both republicans yeah
democrats bipartisan think tanks the
only
like fat study that was ever conducted
that like republicans love showing which
is the american enterprise institute's
like 30-year track of like voter fraud
actually disproves that there is rampant
voter fraud because they only found 1200
instances out of billions of ballots
cast over the course of 30 years of
election well yeah i i and and the thing
is you know all these claims of voter
fraud and them wanting to audit the
systems and claims of hacking and all
this weird [ __ ] going on on the computer
most of these elections are backed up
with paper ballots yeah like it's easy
to check one-to-one and see that the
software is one is working like 99.9
accurate yeah it's complete [ __ ] and
by the way it's not unique to donald
trump people like to always say like oh
donald trump did this donald trump do
this like no
every republican in perpetuity has
always run on elections are fraudulent
illegals are voting that's why we need
to make sure that like you know we have
extra voter security um
and that's why they do like signature
matching that's why they do uh you know
voter id yeah it just gives numerous
other things this gives them space to
throw out ballots and exclude people
exactly and and their goal is to
minimize and that my friends is what a
hog is
yeah
uh you probably saw this clip i love
this one yeah so this is um
my uh mike or no cam so mike is uh
apparently a prominent right-wing pundit
in the uk
um who looks like a hog
yeah
and then he's calling he's my michael
graham from the independent republic
yes so cameron from this um
organization insulate
britain
calls in
to discuss climate change with him
and it's the most flawless victory i've
ever seen and what makes it even more
flawless is that the hog himself posted
the he posted his own cringe yeah no he
he thought he really did something here
i'm gonna tie this
back to the previous thing with dinesh
d'souza
for conservatives it does not matter if
they get owned or not it literally
doesn't matter because cognitive
dissonance and like team sports
mentality is so like permanently wired
to their [ __ ] dome that they see
someone going up against like someone
who's a leftist so obviously a communist
uh and they think oh yeah my guy is
winning no matter what yeah i guess they
i could see how they could write this
off but you you watch and tell me uh
here we go good morning mike hello i
want you glued to cameron
uh just your screen unfortunately
unfortunately what do you do for a
living cameron
i'm a carpenter a carpenter right so how
safe is that for the climate
well i work with timber which is a much
more sustainable material rather than
concrete i also work with trees that
have been cut down then don't you
it's a sustainable building practice how
is it sustainable if you're killing
trees
because it's regenerative you can grow
trees
right
well you can you can grow all sorts of
things can you
well you can't grow concrete you can
see cameron cheerio
that was cameron uh he grows trees and
then cuts them down and then makes
things from them brilliant i mean only
in england guard the uk could you i mean
this is fantastic it's great
but the i mean the total silence of uh
our dear cameron there was so endearing
so fantastic but he get he actually gets
commit so committed to trying to
prove that he's right he does a pull is
it possible to go grow concrete i don't
know what the [ __ ] that means i mean
who's
so no obviously i loved it he tried to
put it out there for himself like well
metaphorically yes right come on chaps
right vote on this so he i mean he got
some support there for sure
metaphorically uh but then he goes oh no
what i meant
oh he had another guest on to like
defend his idea or something yeah
you can actually grow concrete doesn't
it oh my gosh you're going no no what i
meant was this super sustainable cutting
edge concrete growing rocks and turning
it into something that nobody's doing
is is like highly experimental he was
referring to that well yes if you can
grow stone you can effectively turn
carbon dioxide into a variety of growth
stone like materials by feeding it in
different ways using a variety of
different processes it's not necessarily
fast are you talking about um
because he said gr planting a [ __ ]
tree i think we all know what that means
yeah that's pretty uh
i mean everyone knows that concrete
grows on trees of course
which you don't plant it's a
it's a finite resource
dude these guys are awesome so british
conservatives are [ __ ] psychotic okay
a lot of people in america don't know
this like
they think like you know prediction
servers are great because like you know
andrew neal who's like literally a
[ __ ] vulture uh owned ben shapiro
famously one time yeah but like they're
all insane dude first of all they still
have lords
so much inbreeding won't get into that
but like
they're they are just as hog-like as our
uh hogs but they also have like funny
accents and
really in a weird way are just like
absolutely
obsessed pathologically with the age of
consent laws and whatnot i mean they
have oh for real
yes it's a pedophile island over there
well the age you can say in england it's
like 15 or 16 right so
they're they're all [ __ ] turfs and
they're all mission accomplished yeah
and that's why we did brexit no they
have great funny outfits too english uh
yeah
english show me some other funny outfits
would you please 16. just just funny
generally funny well they have these
secret societies where they were they
yeah like david cameron [ __ ] the pig
allegedly allegedly allegedly
in minecraft yeah get at me [ __ ]
we got parody laws up in this [ __ ] in
the united states of america freedom of
speech have you heard of it yeah i don't
guess what i don't think that's
incurring any lawsuits i hope not yeah
it's not necess necessarily being done
at scale right well that's what i meant
i meant uh cutting edge experiment we're
growing concrete yeah no i just i love
in the fundamentals of the process you
are correct yes thank you very much
thank you very much
it's gonna be quite a long time before
you can uh get a big enough tree to cut
down to make into a house hey [ __ ]
you can [ __ ] plant trees ahead of
time they like what the [ __ ] bro
yeah he took such an l he's like doing a
whole also we are not even having a
conversation about like insulation which
is like insulate britain is uh i looked
into this after the interview so i guess
it did work oh yeah so shouts out to
[ __ ] mike over here um
insulate britain simply uh wants to
uh reintegrate like insulation so that
uh like
revamp the way that uh british houses
which are all really old for the most
part uh so that it's like way more
energy efficient when you heat them
and that's it it's like a good idea
overall
uh
the only reason why you'd be against
this is if you're just like
straight up like no the climate change
is not real it's not a real problem you
know
additionally ironics they're in a
[ __ ] island but hey you know yeah so
this this i don't know joe rogan's been
on such a
l streak lately and this one really
pissed me off as a father
with another one on the way i showed
this to ela too she was disgusted
joe rogan is going on the
paternity leave is for beta [ __ ]
uh and americans should be working
especially the men also a little tinge
of homophobia too he's talking about how
beat pete booty judge
uh shouldn't be on paternity leave and
only the person who gave birth should be
on paternity leave which is odd
considering they're both fathers
um and i don't know what's going on with
joe rogan he was just singing praises to
tucker
this is basically like a breitbart
talking point
and it's honestly [ __ ] disgusting
freak show going on over there
i mean you're a you're a fan of joe
rogan so are you do you hope maintain
that uh position or i used to be i used
to be a gigantic fan of joe rogan i mean
i've hung out with him he used to be
like a big uh young turks fan he's come
on the show
yeah yeah yeah and then there was like a
breakdown because of uh
sam harris who
had like a different position on islam
like a very antagonistic position
against islam and then jank who's also
like
otherwise like a very annoying atheist
type for the most part was a pro like
defending you know muslims rights in
this country of course against like
racial discrimination and whatnot and
that was there was like a big debate
that was like three hours long and
basically after that i think like joe
rogan really just like sided with sam
harris and
since then he like you know was a
play a fundamental role in the idw the
intellectual dark web and all that sort
of stuff and he's like truly moved away
from that but i still watch him so
everyone in texas it's like his brain is
just totally rotting yeah yeah there was
i mean he's very malleable he's very
impressionable i think like that's what
makes him great for a lot of people like
he's a he's a guy's guy you know he's
just like me
uh but also uh you know a hundred
millionaire and and has like it commands
an incredible audience
that he uh truly doesn't and i think
like care about misinforming and which
is a really which sucks
well this take is just [ __ ] horrible
here it is
what's crazy is that pete buddha judge
during this whole time is on paternity
leave and you just want to go listen man
i understand it's hard to raise a child
but um
isn't that supposed to be for the person
who gave birth okay so stop right there
no two fathers
so neither so pete and his husband
uh adopted a child
from a surrogate mother who basically
gave birth and according to joe if
you're a gay couple you are not entitled
to any uh paternity leave your child
should you should never real men don't
basically real men don't care about
their kids everybody knows that
everyone knows
that if you are a gay couple and you
adopted you can literally just leave
your child and like
you know just leave like you know little
cups of water maybe a sandwich right not
even [ __ ] that actually you know if you
have like a like a three-year-old or a
two-year-old or whatever the [ __ ] at
home just leave the things that you can
make a sandwich for and make the baby
figure it out like a baby deer well this
is day one [ __ ] right so day one is like
just leave the formula and the water and
they'll take care of the uh joe rogan
you know clearly i feel like this is
proof that this [ __ ] was not uh
very involved with uh raising his kids
at a young birth uh young age he
probably when you think about joe
rogan's probably a good thing though
what it's probably a good thing he
wasn't very involved in raising his
daughters
i'm just saying yeah we'll see about
that i don't know
generally speaking i think uh
kids like having their dads around
surprising uh kids need their parents
surprising
and there's this whole theory in in
america still that these people are
pushing is that dads should be going out
and bringing home the ba it's weird
because they're like on one hand men's
rights
wins right man
what like the jordan peterson what would
we be without men yeah you saw that he's
crying where would i be without men
building her up but on the other hand
they go men don't [ __ ] need to spend
time with their families
it's their newborn baby
and gay men don't even literally like
this is literally a labor rights issue
and and also a men's rights issue as
well yeah and they're just completely
missing not a men's rights issue well
anyway here they go on yeah
yes men can take paternity leave yeah
paternity leave is what men take
joe rogan [ __ ] brain rot rogan
as opposed to maternity leave which is
what mothers take
100 000 containers are waiting off shore
there's a hundred thousand containers
waiting offshore we got men taking
paternity leave yeah
and it's like they're they're like upset
that pete buddhist is just taking
paternity only pete would have not taken
time off to spend with his first born uh
yeah child i mean i just i dislike pete
buddha judge i'm not a fan okay
cia pete buddha judge but
uh you know
well regardless of if you like him
you're not the man yeah exactly like he
he can take paternity leave i think it's
a bigger issue is that
it's funny again it's just so ironic
this is a men's right thing men deserve
the chance to bond with their newborn
baby and guess what kids need their
daddies too man there's research on it
too there uh take men who take paternity
leave are less likely to get divorced
which is a big problem for joe rogan
he's he's missed their divorce court
like that's what jordan peterson
mink
people are getting divorced it's ruining
our society yeah
the real dragon of chaos is actually
divorce court
activist judges working in divorce court
working for communist ideals
yeah like alimony there's no [ __ ]
consistency in their
in their thoughts
yeah um here is by the way a little
refresher what was this the crying video
yeah yeah did you i love this so much
what the hell are we gonna do without
men what are we gonna do with you look
around the city here you see all these
buildings what the [ __ ] with the monitor
bro it's like going crazy are you seeing
it there these men they're doing
impossible things they're under the
streets that's just the video oh it is
it's like a filter okay my bad
that's a sick filter bro
no i love the unironic like red pill
knowledge account that's like posting
which is just basically a dude crying
what are we gonna do without men yeah no
it's it's uh you know anyone else that
cries they're lame they're whack jordan
peterson cries brave uh also you're
you're engaging in what is known as
toxic masculinity if you make fun of me
for being emotional when i think about
the hard bodies of men working in a hot
sauce
yeah what are we men with their
beautiful bodies it's freaking getting
chiseled
it's like i care about men i do uh and
that's why i am an advocate for not only
paternity leave but like better wages
you know better workplace missions yeah
better workplaces and time higher
salaries what are we going to do without
men yeah it's like anyway
he loves when men are exploited that's
why he's crying he just wants them to be
you know exploited further
i cry every time a man a man stays home
with his newborn baby
he needs to be out there building roads
building skyscrapers from what i
understand canada's roads are dog [ __ ]
so
maybe they should be taking this between
uh we're only 19 seconds into this rodeo
but he was saying this like this
negative feedback loop that is rapidly
cycling out of control that if it
continues on a bait it will destroy the
global economy i'm like that's a nice
one to just slide in there
yeah
um so it's complicated but i do know the
trucking stuff has something to do with
it too because there was already
problems with truckers they kind of
abandoned california what does it look
like two years ago oh my god
what a [ __ ] like why why do you just
like say
like a half truth there's a problem with
trucking first of all truckers are hella
unionized in [ __ ] california and they
make bank like truckers and teamsters
incredibly powerful union a little bit
of corruption there too but whatever
they're working through it but like
truckers they're incredibly they're they
have a good union um you know unionized
drugs make a lot of money they get good
benefits it's great it's a great way to
make a living the problem with the
trucking industry currently is that uh
there is a there's an item necessary for
trucks to operate that because of the
microchip shortage is simply not
available so a lot of the trucks are in
a state of disrepair as a consequence of
that and it has nothing to do with
truckers being like yeah i'm going to
austin like shut the [ __ ] up i don't
know anything you just like made that up
you're literally that's the whole circle
jerk in that room is that california's
[ __ ] and everybody's coming to texas i
just i [ __ ] hate it when they do this
[ __ ] like when they just take like a
half truth that they heard from someone
and then add their own seasoning and
spin to it it's like shut the [ __ ] up i
feel like okay all that happens there
these days like the data they use so
we're watching trucks this is a couple
of seconds
just a couple ships this is 2019 last
week
why are there so many
because they're all i mean this is wow
that's why pretty complicated
space to come into there to go wait and
they can kind of get in there like you
said if there's only seven out of
hundreds of cranes emptying them then
they're waiting
it's nuts
it's nuts and that's why you can't buy
toys and it's also affecting small
businesses yeah you know it's just
forget about that definitely feels like
that's what we're talking about but
who's responsible is this like people
are blaming people yeah because the fact
that he's on paternity leave yeah yeah
if he wasn't on paternity leave none of
this would happen he would be unloading
the [ __ ] uh he'd be going to the long
beach port and unloading personally was
not being a deadbeat beta males caring
about his kid
he would have fixed the he would have
made the port be able to hold more
containers overnight something that
would usually take 10 15 20 years
he would have got the microchips for the
trucks
he would have um
no p pete's got pete's forklift
certified he could do it
um yeah no these guys are longshoremen
uh stevedores uh teamsters these guys
are [ __ ]
they are literally like there is an
actual labor shortage right now going on
uh there's there's a tight labor market
they have so much power if it were up to
me listen if any of you guys are
listening to the leftovers podcast
dude now is your time it is better than
ever for you to just be like
that benefits package that you were
looking for that's a little bit better
[ __ ] it you can ask for it you could
literally
functionally
stop the entirety of the united states
economy like
straight up well we're almost there at
this point but yeah and also the demand
is up it's a very complicated uh issue
but like it's just amazing it's
incredible to me we're in an asset
bubble demand is up everybody's got
money in their pockets and they want to
purchase [ __ ] uh and they are purchasing
and then there's also issues where china
was locked the [ __ ] down because of kova
they're still having problems uh because
they're they keep it so tight unlike
america if there's like a small outbreak
they shut the whole [ __ ] port down
and so shit's backed up there at the
export show it's about it's it's kind of
a global issue there's a container
shortage too there's another but the
truth of the matter is
is that yeah there's a container
shortage is that pete booty judge
uh if you wouldn't just not spend time
with his newborn child than we would be
saying he's the secretary of
transportation does that make any sense
um i'm not sure i mean that that was a
weird one because i never know in those
stories it's like uh is this just like a
partisan thing where you just want to
like yell at the guy because but it is
kind of crazy
it's not it is
the craziest thing to me was the picture
of them in the [ __ ] hospital bed yeah
that's where i was like
like you didn't you weren't in a
hospital
i mean yeah so they went and got their
kid from the hospital from the surrogate
mom and now their thing is two gay men
in a hospital bed would you would you
[ __ ] that baby out it's like just you're
not allowed in there why can't they just
like have fun i don't understand why
can't they just be normal [ __ ]
parents i mean i've done this too
everybody it's it's a little bit of
homophobia like the underlying component
that person might not be homophobic at
all
like that but you know what i mean it's
like it's it's without
meaning to be homophobic it's like one
of those things where you're just like
being homophobic and then also misogyny
too like the rock when he had a child
yeah um one thing that you do is you
hold your baby and you want to do
skin-to-skin contact uh with your child
i think it's like important uh i forget
why but i did not know that either so
when i saw the rock post about like his
uh you know newborn baby that he was
holding i was like man what did you
[ __ ] give birth to the child like
what the [ __ ] why did you do this photo
shoot and it turns out it's like
actually an important thing and that's
misogyny it's like that's where that
comes from or like fathers are not
supposed to be uh you know taking an
active role in the development of their
child in the early stages or whatever
the [ __ ] that's like the underlying
reason for that i feel like that caused
more harm like societally than many
things is that dads are meant to feel
that they should be cold and [ __ ]
unavailable and unemotional and not
invested in a child's life especially a
young child's life which is absolutely
[ __ ] to the family dynamic and to
men's psychological welfare who just
want to love their kids and their kids
just want to be loved by their dad
um
it's it's it is toxic as [ __ ] and it's
horrific you know if you want to talk
about men and we care about men and we
don't want divorce like you said i mean
that's it
and it's like conservatives the other
thing is like people dunking on people
judge uh a lot of them are conservative
and they're making this joke about like
how they adopted a child they didn't
actually give birth to it whatever
and it's wild to me because like well i
thought you guys were [ __ ] pro-life
you know not joe rogan but like a lot of
these conservatives probably life oh but
not kidding but yeah but like you know
we don't want gay people i'd rather that
kid oh i wish that kid was aborted i
didn't know he's going to a gay parent
yeah what the [ __ ] it's like yeah not
like that no we don't we don't want to
we don't want to let the gays adopt
they're like okay if
if you were
if your kid was born of incest or we'll
give them to the gays
normal babies go to heterosexuals
um i don't know if they were there for
the you know surgery
for the birth maybe the the the you know
surrogate was but it wasn't
they were in the house they really think
they went to like a hospital for a photo
shoot and got into bed like it's just
[ __ ] psychotic we're on the bed but i
think they were doing that
i'm talking about i haven't even seen
the photo
but yeah exactly but that is the reason
why fathers do that
um yeah i mean it's called exactly they
they
the doctors tell you to do it basically
right after the kid's born and they
charge you a lot of money for it as a
matter of fact there's nothing wrong
with this photo guys
you know what i'll tell you what it is
you go into a room the surrogate's
probably right next to them in another
bed and they're sleeping in that bed
that's what it was when elo gave birth
you get your private room
and that's what it is so there you have
oh they got twins
um
yeah and they all right
they also lied and said that like he
um he had like a breastfeeding thing
uh there's like a digitally altered
image of people who just wearing a
breastfeeding device
um by the way people do that too there's
honestly nothing wrong with it
especially if you're you know two dads
like that i've seen i i mean i've seen
it where
dudes can get abreast
yeah exactly it's a real product oh
that's such a shitty photoshop too
yeah but again like is there what is the
criticism here even if it's real you
know
this is the man
pete
gets [ __ ] paternity leave in a time
of like you know a supply chain crisis
or whatever but like the democrats are
not advocating for [ __ ] paid uh uh
family leave uh for for the american
worker the criticism of the fake tit
breastfeeding oh oh that's not a beta
yeah i don't know yeah no
who cares yeah exactly no i don't care
birthing table yeah yeah
that is that's what's weird
i would love that i would love the
breastfeeding thing for one of my but
here's the thing i would want one of my
homies to have that so i could suck
along their breasts uh you know take
tequila shots directly oh yeah that's my
home express you know what i'm saying
like that's
you know fun stuff you could do with
that a lot of utility for next week if
you'd like a little
yeah i will i will let you drip feed
i'll do it
just to show that men can be sensitive
loving people put some cold brew in
there it's early in the morning i'll
just it'll be a men's rights moment
yeah this will be a roomba this will be
our red pilled moment can you get that
dan yeah we'll see if i can i will
suckle on your breasts it's called the
red-pilled moment
yeah
one of you should do that
one of you should take care of the
children like this idea that both
parents should get maternity and
paternity leave at the same time it's a
little weird i don't think so
i don't only because his guest keeps
pushing back and he he doesn't let up i
have a german cousin and they get the
[ __ ] i mean they get like a full year
for the woman and nine months for the
husband that's great you want to live in
germany because in america you got to
work like here's the thing if you have a
small business that's such a [ __ ] up
thing to say like yo it's not like
germany's by the way germany is last
time i checked is a pretty affluent uh
country and those people are not known
for slacking off either by the way yeah
no they're
they're they're dying out there they're
not like america a very productive
country with like the only viable
industry being weapons of war
manufacturing so people didn't choose to
come to america and not get paternity
leave you want to live in america you
better work
that's so dumb it's such a [ __ ] silly
thing for like a hundred millionaire
podcast owner to say yeah because you
could afford to take any time off you
want get all the help
in the world you clearly never [ __ ]
like spent time with your newborn kids
based on this take
he probably has 20 nannies the thing i
used to love about joe rogan is that
despite like his affluent uh situation
now
the fact that he like grew up in in
poverty in i think newark if i'm not
mistaken or in jersey city the fact that
he grew up in a situation like that
really motivated him to understand the
perspective of other people who have
been in shitty situations like that and
he could apply that to like even you
know uh black people and and numerous
other like uh intersections of
marginalization and the more he's in
[ __ ] texts the more he like hangs out
with ben shabibo and all these other
[ __ ] dildos he's the
further he moves away from that it's so
strange to see it's like dude i just
wish you would have more
left uh left-leaning people chelsea
gabbard
it's just it's annoying because i would
like to watch him engage in a
conversation with somebody that you know
actually knows these issues yeah i mean
he he'll have abby martin on every now
and then liberals
um he'll have evan martin on every now
and then he has kyle kalinski on every
now and then david pacquiao when's the
last time he had any of those guys on
i don't think i liked him it was
actually relatively recently who which
one abby martin i think i saw yeah abby
martin was a reason
um there are some like leftist or left
adjacent people that he has on that he
likes personally but even then like it's
rarely ever contentious because
well one he's again he's a chameleon
that's what makes him really good he'll
literally adopt to your position and
like become a champion of it with the
exception of covid uh misinfo that he
spreads and like ivermectin and stuff
but other than that he usually is like
yeah that's right yeah you know what i
see yeah we must seize the means of
production actually it seems like a good
idea
and then next week he's like yeah
workers should [ __ ] get [ __ ] if by
the way
just for reference joe uh if you want to
live in america you got to work rogan
time off for kids across 41 wealthy
countries in the eu
the amount of paid leave for mothers and
fathers varies substantially estonia
crushing it where does this even go this
is 70 to 80 days here's the united
states by the way those are weirdos no
these are weeks yes sir [ __ ]
yeah look at this [ __ ] even in japan
these guys literally work themselves to
death people are killing well there's a
reason for that because they are uh
not very pro-immigration and their
country is [ __ ] dying like they're so
old and they they work so much that they
weren't having kids the population in
japan they wanted they want to improve
yeah they want to improve birth rates
but yeah look at all these countries in
a state of disarray like economic
meltdown happening in finland
people you know chile [ __ ] poland
dude even poland you know greece turkey
when you're getting lapsed by turkey
israel by the way which is not a
working-class utopia mexico
uh and then here we are joe joe we care
about men
we native men
yeah in america you [ __ ] give birth
a mother give birth and if you haven't
seen the process it's [ __ ]
horrif it's traumatic it's
hard on the body you're straddled with a
newborn baby the most like precious and
uh uh
fragile thing you can imagine
two [ __ ] weeks by the way this is yet
another argument for uh pro-lifers too
like if you have maternity leave and
paternity leave you're significantly
more likely to carry that right maybe
the term because now you're not going to
suffer the economic repercussions of
like back to work having a [ __ ] child
beta [ __ ] male 1 figure it out
yeah
yeah just give birth on your lunch break
and then come back
two basically two weeks you get most
country you get two [ __ ] weeks to be
with your newborn baby and then your ass
is back to work
wow that's just
yeah that's cool states rights you know
and that's another problem like
obviously a lot of states have like
maternity leave or california even if
it's not enforced like a lot of uh you
know a lot of of
um companies offer it
but clearly it's not like you know if
that was the case then it should be
regulated to the federal level at the
very least it's a massive quality of
life improvement it there are numer like
there's not a single study that's like
maternity leave and paternity leave is
bad it's ruining you know yeah there's
that's never happened and it never will
happen and we already have an incredibly
productive labor force
that uh it works
it's so [ __ ] annoying yeah and also
like who joe rogan basically says you
live in america get back to work i mean
he's basically just simping for
billionaires uh company owners you know
who
yeah who uh
yeah at one point he says what do you do
if you're a company owner and then all
of a sudden one of your workers needs to
take
you know six months off yeah jamie like
what if jamie has uh you know what if
jamie has a child you know you're not
gonna let jamie hang out with his child
no it's [ __ ] up joe let jamie do that
pull it get someone else to pull that
[ __ ] it's like
your workers are not
your property they're not their life is
not defined by serving you i mean
there's things in life more important
than work i think it's time that we
[ __ ] acknowledge that in some small
measure
yeah that's how little that's a little
benefits like
american the american labor force has
though like that
this is like
a matter of discussion
that is like beyond the scope of
comprehension where people are like what
paternity leave that's crazy we don't
even have maternity leave in this
country and it's like yeah that's an
issue like that's a major [ __ ]
problem right and who does that benefit
[ __ ] jeff bezos and elon musk who are
worth 200 billion yeah and i mean small
business owners as well if they're
[ __ ] small business tyrants well you
know the problem is the government is to
subsidize you know uh this [ __ ] like
obviously do do can can all small
businesses afford to float somebody for
six months while they don't work
obviously not that's why the government
subsidizes [ __ ] yeah well don't worry
the government's not subsidizing [ __ ] no
no [ __ ]
no leave no vacation time
joe rogan wins again yeah
get back to work bud
yeah matt walsh by the way
uh my favorite
matt walsh has become basically my
favorite uh psychopathic conservative i
follow him on twitter and it's like a
daily occurrence
this is the guy who said the
um
inquisition was more justified than woke
culture
yeah yeah yeah it was a brilliant
insightful analysis and true so here's
another tweet came out recently
uh on the 22nd a listener wrote to ask
if it's a red flag that his fiancee
doesn't want to take his last name no
it's not just a red flag it's a deal
breaker men don't marry women who won't
take your name that's a wall of
separation she wants to keep between you
it will
it won't be the only one so matt here is
saying
dumper
dump that beach
bro if you're a matt walsh
if you're a matt walsh fan
and a woman agreed to be around you let
alone have sex with you that's a keeper
okay yeah you don't get to make you
don't get to make demands
all right you're not like oh my god
you're not gonna take my last name like
what the [ __ ] you listen to matt walsh
dude yeah i mean basically on the first
date you should be asking if we get
married will you take my last name
because it's a deal breaker if you want
to do any of this hyphenated beta [ __ ]
yeah
exactly but this is what so shout out
but this is what sticks like look at
that 1 900 retweets like that's what
conservatives want to talk about more
than the fact that like paid family
leave was completely taken off the
[ __ ] infrastructure bill get back
that hurts them no but there's people
it's crazy that people are openly saying
get back to work it's america like dude
who are you advocating for who are you
advocating for when you say that no
you're you're a bootlicker cook and
that's why i always ask when people come
in and they're like oh well what the
[ __ ] like you know you're wrong actually
workers need to [ __ ] uh do more for
their bosses or whatever i'm like listen
dude show me the d deer factory you
claim to be a capitalist yet you have no
deed to the factory that's not what your
company can do for you ask how you can
earn your company
more money
with no more wages and no benefits
this is scary bro
this actually scares me no i'm tucker
carlson is stoking the flames of civil
war they love this
um he's made a documentary
on the january 6
you know capital riots
and
it's in full spin
he's made a full documentary about how
it was a false flag
and basically there was no conservatives
there it was all antifa
it was a friendly tour yeah i can't wait
to watch this masterpiece i'm gonna be
honest it's gonna be good content for
you yeah i it's it's uh it terrifies me
it actually scares me yeah no it's wild
at fox news is doing what they did to
bill o'reilly which is like they made
bill really the face of the network yeah
and now tucker carlson is the new face
of the network and unfortunately that
face of the network literally is just
like i am a populist
proto-fascist or full-blown fashion as a
matter of fact
i'm a wasp nationalist and i don't give
a [ __ ] i will do a straight up infowars
style documentary on the january 6 uh
insurrection yeah you got to watch this
it's terrifying what you're about to see
is part of our soon to be released
three-part series for tucker carlson
originals it's called patriot purge it
debuts november 1st
already off to a great start the drums
of war baby
are we pogba's again straight up this
woman being killed yeah in the trailer i
love that you know how there was like
riot shields in the cops in the
beginning
that was not happening on january 6th
okay they opened the [ __ ] floodgates
brother yeah i wish that i wish that
that was there yeah that had all been
avoided that woman would not have been
killed yeah exactly if only that was the
true case this documentary wouldn't even
exist
[Music]
yeah this is isn't this like
revolutionary war
uh
drum beat like yeah walking drum beats
marching drum beats yeah that's well you
know the other war that he's uh more
fond of the civil war he can't really
openly side with you know he's trying
his best man yeah he's like he's trying
yeah
why do we not talk about the northern
aggression against southern states that
simply wanted states rights yeah
what's the was the civil war a mistake
uh should we have gone our separate ways
back in uh 1860
and is it too late
the domestic war on terror is here
is coming after
the patriot birds
of the country
no come in
oh yes
oh yes yeah you know oh no
yeah but you know lots of people watches
so everyone's like you know this is this
is so dangerous the worst part about it
is like there are things that i do agree
with that like i do think that the fbi
has like taken a more like liberal turn
with respect to like doing i talked
about this i think even here um like
with what happened with governor
whitmer's kidnapping uh plot that they
foiled that was straight out of [ __ ]
post uh 911 fbi antics like the the way
that they like
agitated a bunch of hogs to like you
know and then show them where the
tannerite was you know i mean it's like
come on i just don't what are they
trying to do they do that for propaganda
justify inflating budgets and uh whip
people up in a [ __ ] frenzy so you can
continue the surveillance they probably
think it's fun yeah i mean they did that
with like autistic teenage muslim boys
back in the day and like they would
[ __ ] that's a good dub for the fbi
you know what i mean like oh we did it
we stopped another terror plot and it's
like no you literally started a terror
plot and then stopped it
like this dude would have not done this
like you just you gave them the tools
you gave them the [ __ ] radicalization
so you're saying you agree with the
premise
so i do think civil war was a mistake
well
yeah i agree with tucker carlson
completely okay no no no i spencer
ackerman friend of the show uh he's a
brilliant natsec reporter he actually
wrote a book literally on this talking
about and he covered the entire uh you
know throughout the duration like 2001
onward he was he was always on wired and
and you know new republican and plenty
other outlets where he was uh
agitational against the iraq war and
against the surveillance state and
against the patriot act for
understandable reasons and he makes this
comparison about white supremacist
militias and white supremacist terror
um he literally starts off his book
reign
by talking about timothy mcveigh
and uh how different the way that
we as a society analyze
acts of of white terror uh when it comes
to domestic terror versus what we
consider foreign entities uh like in 911
and there are
similarities in the way that like the
fbi is operating but ultimately uh the
reality is white supremacy is baked into
all of our institutions including the
fbi holy [ __ ]
uh great kind of the whole history of
the fbi are getting a critical race
there now yeah so it's not like they're
never going to prosecute like
three percenters and oath keepers and
and like
white anti-government extremist militias
and whatnot in the same fervor that they
uh uh persecute and prosecute and go
after you know uh other groups like even
70 year old like greenpeace activist you
know what i mean like
you you just it's not it's not going to
happen because it goes a long way isn't
that what they did with the governor and
the guys who try to kidnap the governor
they did that that was like a one-off
for the most part though like they're
the thing is like the january six
insurrection was insane like that was an
insane [ __ ] thing that happened it's
not normal the fact that we act like
that's like a totally normal thing and
we've moved well no it's not it's even
worse he's whitewashing it and making it
turn into it was actually the liberals
that stormed the capitol yeah no i love
that actually [ __ ] crazy no i i i
love that
let's go let's let it ride i i have a
take on that it looks so funny let's
watch the whole thing here's have left
afghanistan and now they've landed here
at home
i'm sorry it's so hard not to pause yeah
the troops have left afghanistan and
they've arrived here at home the
helicopters he's like such
a spin master
yeah i mean the the
the police are the ones being
militarized against [ __ ] protesters
not yeah
the police are not targeting
conservatives they are conservatives
yeah
members have left afghanistan and now
they've landed here at home on the left
is hunting the right sticking them in
guantanamo bay for american citizens
leaving them there to rot we are dealing
with an insurgency they couldn't find a
white guy that they could waterboard for
that one they still ended up putting
like a brown dude that's being
waterboarded
that's awesome but yeah
white guy dude come on
right yeah favorite well are you saying
black time
for american citizens leaving them there
to rot we are dealing with an insurgency
in the united states terrorism from
white supremacy is the most lethal
threat to homelessness
yeah why are you guys so worried about
why did they show the kkk rallies again
because he go exactly he goes white
supremacy is the biggest terrorist group
in the united states and then tucker's
like excuse me white supremacists are
good people
like i don't understand i know i don't
understand why he showed the kkk rally
what's that supposed to mean theory is
that they're trying to paint all
god loving patriots as uh white
supremacists
and therefore they're coming for half of
america there's a lot of them for sure
but i mean
if you're worried that someone's going
to call you a white
nationalist you probably
probably may want to second guess your
their insurgency in the united states
terrorism from white supremacy is the
most legal threat to homelessness i've
been told that i'm a white nationalist
me
i mean that's [ __ ] ali uh whatever
the [ __ ]
yeah i mean he kind of is right yeah he
he'd like i mean you don't have i mean
yeah you can you can be like a brown
dude i mean first of all
he's got hella white supremacist uh
jeans at the very least he's got the
habsburg jaw going and [ __ ] like he's
got that
that's like straight white people [ __ ]
okay uh you know centuries of [ __ ]
inbreeding causes
white people to to some white people in
the royal family to have like their very
own
uh
habsburg jaw
genetic disorder so that he does have
that have you seen that motherfucker's
chin no yeah he's wild yeah yeah you uh
bro come on yeah
me
there he is
yeah god
god damn dude my mother yo my dude looks
like a royal dude he looks like he's
rolling the austria hungry he's got that
royal inbreeding dude nice
good for him
false flags have happened in this
country
what's the name of the guy who made the
transformer movies
michael bay yeah he really thinks he's
making a michael bay movie here i love
that it may have been january 6.
this is disturbing
yeah this is i mean this is straight in
fours the thing i was gonna say is at
the end it's like
well you know what a false flag is like
this is one of those it's like okay
here's the thing
if you admit that then you're basically
stating that what happened on january 6
was not a bunch of [ __ ] patriots that
were just simply exercising their right
to like their freedom of assembly okay
so you're saying they did bad [ __ ] so if
the dudes that did bad [ __ ] were like
maggot up you know what i mean and they
were they got [ __ ] hell of mega [ __ ]
on uh then you're saying that they were
here's what a false flag looks like
yeah yeah look at all those antifa
brother that's right me and the boys we
we went to the [ __ ] capitol
actually i you know
mm-hmm
yeah and weirdly all the people being
arrested are like yeah it's coming out
they're all
sp dude they've been so deep uncovered
they've been spending uh uh writing maga
conspiracy q anon conspiracies on
facebook for like years
there was a new study that just came out
that showed well it wasn't even a study
it was like leaked documents that showed
like eighteen thousand uh three percent
are like oath keeper uh militia members
uh where they originally found out about
the oath keepers that joined one of
these like groups and i think like the
top the top thing was facebook
and then um and then like uh youtube
like these are the places where they got
radicalized in the joining like you know
these sorts of
anti-government militias
right-wing anti-government militias
next one civil war watch comes from
charlie clark i mean this this ties
perfectly into you know the previous
thing that we were looking at
exactly and you know this guy's
obviously uh
a deep undercover antifa as well no he's
a brave patriot he showed up to a
charlie curt and again this is
well here i'll just play this this ties
in perfectly
you ready
you're brave you're brave for what you
said and the fact that you stand up
there and say it and i appreciate it
yeah
he's so brave dude i'm confused um no no
this is good it's perfect appreciate it
actually because there's not a lot of
people
that have the balls to do it
but i want to ask you something a little
bit out of the ordinary no no one has
the balls to say so brad yourself
at this point we're living under
corporate and medical fascism this is
tyranny
when do we get to use the guns
no and i i'm not that's not a joke i'm
not saying it like that i mean literally
where's the line how many elections are
they going to steal before we kill these
people so
yeah i love that let me clarify no no no
let me clarify when do i get to start
killing libs yeah yeah um he's right we
do live under corporate and medical
tyranny and fascism but always of course
as the case with like right-wing
commentary it's them his anger is
literally
misdirected and focused on perfectly
misdirected the wrong things like we do
have corporate fascism or or medical
fascism but it's not because like
everyone can get a [ __ ] vaccine or
it's not because like facebook you know
abandonment profile when i said you know
i'm going to go out and kill people like
no that's not corporate fascism dumb ass
corporate fascism is like you not
getting benefits you being a more
productive worker as a consequence of
technological improvements and and yet
not seeing any not realizing any of the
[ __ ] profits that you generate for
the company that you work for one of the
things he cites is that how many
elections are going to steal and it's
all of course the republicans who are uh
putting every effort into limiting
voting and trying to definitely overturn
a stolen election like the most like
hard proof
of a stolen election in contemporary
american society is the 2000 election in
florida the brooks brothers riots like
that was literally a [ __ ] stolen
election jeb bush george w bush's
brother uh the governor and the
right-wing slanted supreme court
basically allowed
after revolts occurred uh for florida to
not do a [ __ ] recount
and they successfully stole that and
george w bush became president one of
the worst presidents if not probably the
worst president of all time um
that happened they did steal an election
they straight up stole it
and and the other side of it like voter
fraud individuals like on their own
volition going out on like you know
doing electoral fraud or voter fraud in
a systemic capacity has never happened
there's no proof for it the only proof
is the exact opposite that it literally
does not happen because it's
insane to get that many people to
coordinate with one another like who the
[ __ ] cares about the government that
much they're like i really
dude i really really need to make sure
kirsten gillibrand is a [ __ ] senator
you know what i mean like i'm gonna go
do illegal voting for them
well ted liu like that's the reason why
i you know brought up all of my
undocumented friends together and we uh
stole ballots from the [ __ ] uh
from the from the old folks home well
the the problem is is like
charlie kirk and and tucker carlson a
lot of these guys
they have basically
told people for so long that the
election has been stolen that these
people are evil
uh that you're living in tyranny uh
fascism it's like if everything they
said was true
then violence would be justified yeah so
then all of a sudden for sure charlie
kirk is confronted with the result of
his
of his propaganda now watch how he
reacts but like if you believe what
they're saying then
you know
it's justified what he's saying and
that's what's so [ __ ] up
no hold on
no stop hold on
now i'm going to denounce that and tell
you why why you're playing into all
their plans and they're trying to make
you do this that's okay just hear me out
they're trying to make you start with
the compliments so at least
it's like i'm saying he's back guys like
no [ __ ] you're trying to make me
do this yeah you're the one who told me
that they're stealing the elections why
are you back here if you're living in a
fascist country he he has a valid point
right he believes you charlie so so tell
him when does he get to use starting no
the guns that is the logical conclusion
yeah exactly he's right charlie he's
just listening to you and you know and
again they're all about the first
amendment it's like okay so we got the
guns
second amendment sorry we've got the
guns
when do we use them yeah you know that's
why we have them right charlie
they are trying to provoke you
and everyone here they are trying to
make you do something
that will be violent
that will justify a takeover of your
freedoms and liberties the likes of
which we have never seen we are close
to have hold on we are close
to have momentum to be able to get this
country back on a trajectory using the
peaceful means that we have at us
seriously yeah no if you [ __ ]
re-elect a oran hatch that's how you're
gonna [ __ ] win the the war against
like uh
uh the new patriot act against whites
you know what i mean this is what
really makes me think charlie kirk is a
straight-up grifter that doesn't even
believe the [ __ ] he says because if he
did he would they would all be [ __ ]
guns in hand overthrowing the government
because the elections are illegitimate
yeah
that's right
what do you do when the elections are
illegitimate you get your gun and you
[ __ ] you know go to war the
difference between that guy and charlie
kirk is that like that guy at least
thought
the arguments through exactly and that's
the logical conclusion of that
one-on-one together and charlie's like
no no that's not what i meant charlie on
the other hand you can see him like
reboot every time this happens he's like
going up the dialogue tree like a
[ __ ] npc's like
what do i have for violent uh agitated
propaganda
yeah you should vote extra harder uh you
should vote extra hard uh next time i
think that's how we win
uh the the the yeah he doesn't
he's just in it for the grift he doesn't
want the revolution he doesn't want the
violence he just wants to keep making
money well like what violence like they
already control everything like
that's the reason you know what i mean
they control everything conservatives
and reactionary politicians they control
the [ __ ] court system
damn near in its entirety even the
liberals themselves are like feckless
capitalists uh who will defend nestle's
rights to you know have slaves and steal
indigenous uh
land and water supply
like
there's nothing so that's why
when you keep agitating when you're
already the dominant power that's how
you get to
like straight up brown shirt militia
[ __ ] you know what i mean
because there's nothing to fight against
yeah well and notice how he doesn't say
well that's psychotic we don't want to
go murder people
uh it's illegal and uh
psychotic he goes no no no no we're not
there yet
just vote means that we have at us so to
answer your question
and i just think it's you know overly
blunt it's a little it's just it's
overly blunt when do we get to kill
people the aesthetics of what you're so
blunt it's not very civil it's just a
little blunt um your your bloodthirsty
the violent rage is not very civil right
now um i don't like it it's just time if
you would have perhaps said uh when do
we get to uh
you know start a civil war then that
would be fine but just less specific
please ones that do not play into the
violent aims and ambitions of the other
side they fear they're violent let me
say this you got a goo dude in your
audience saying when do i get to kill
people
you
psyched even then it's the fault of the
dems it's the libs that [ __ ] you know
you want to own the liptards is so hard
that like ultimately it's still the lip
tars that are responsible for this guy
being like no i want to kill you they're
violet
it's depressing and it's terrifying i
mean these people are
are dangerous and psychotic and i think
it's time to kill them
i'm just kidding no jesus i'm just
trying a little blunt i'm sorry just a
little blunt
back it up i don't even i'm not yeah
i'm not even a second amendment guys
very clearly they fear us
holding the line with self-control no i
hear you with a gun
no no that's way scarier no i think
liberals fear
guys like that
yeah by the way i'm gonna murder i'm
gonna do a murderer and by the way
at fbi please uh [ __ ] background
check this [ __ ]
yeah no i'm definitely scared of that's
the off-duty cop so
yeah you know what i mean in board
meetings
to use federal force against us and i
know that people get fired up we are
living under fascism we are living under
this tears fired up this [ __ ]
city wants to kill people damn but if
you think for a second that they're not
wanting you to all of a sudden get that
next level where they're going to say
okay we need patriarch 2.0 if you think
that you know waco is bad what do you
say his argument it doesn't even it's
not even logical
what's this whole second amendment guns
right [ __ ] about if it there's no
point to use it he's saying no no no we
never use our guns
it's just we're living in a society
where the election is stolen every year
nothing is legitimate and everybody's
lying to you
also does charlie kirk not support the
patriot act
yeah that's the wonderful part about
that is that like uh these guys are now
like they're libertarian right even
though you know they're they're not
they're obviously not libertarian
because like he's like anti-weed anti-uh
you know
anti-choice
uh so he's not libertarian at all but
they love to adopt the aesthetics of
like uh you know civil war paranism and
he's like oh the surveillance state it's
just
yeah he's talking about when it targets
white dudes yeah specifically see what
they want to do next
what i'm saying is that we have a very
fragile balance right now at our current
time where we must exhaust every single
peaceful mean possible i will say this
then we shoot like what next day like
what more do you want though like do you
like what
what is what does that guy want that
someone else hasn't told him is the
reason why he should be mad you know
what i mean
like from a political point of view if
you're like a [ __ ] republican voter
like you're getting pretty much
everything i mean i guess like you just
want to deny freedom uh and civil
liberties to like marginalize people
that's the issue i i suspect where it's
like yeah i don't like that you know
black people get to
you know drink from the same water
fountain as me but like other than that
it's like
the guys that you're voting for they get
their agenda passed all the time right
fat tax cuts more war in the middle of
their life still suck and they don't
understand why yeah
their lives [ __ ] suck they're not
growing girls man they're broke they're
wage slaves they don't they can't afford
health care they can't afford insulin
for their parents who are not medical
fascism though the medical fascism is
when you get free
vaccine
for so you don't [ __ ] die in a
hospital that is what they're talking
about ironically yeah
it's insane uh by the way the tour is
called exposing critical racism tour so
there you have it yeah well he did
expose and exercise the peaceful means
of state sovereignty against the federal
government not even close i'll give you
five things idaho could do right now the
governor of idaho could sign an
executive order that says there are no
vaccine mandates for private for public
for anyone it's not going to happen he
could do that right now
i just can't get over the fact that
these guys are ready to kill people over
a vaccine mandate like i just can't i
can't
number two
the governor of idaho could come out and
he could say okay blm bureau of land
management epa you're out we're
governing our own lands we're in control
of our own this is why you want to go to
civil war over [ __ ]
epa i mean
no it does make sense
it does make sense because that is the
real goal of the dudes who's paying him
you know what i mean but these people
the epa has already gutted his [ __ ] so
they want to they want to gut it further
i guess so here here here's what's
keeping us
between the civil war so far vaccine
mandates environmental regulations these
are all things that greatly affect the
working classes you know three
idaho could now could pick and choose
through the state legislature which one
of the federal laws they think actually
applies to the idaho constitution these
things i don't think that's how federal
law works
what the [ __ ] does that mean
pick and choose which federal law
applies to them what the [ __ ] does that
even mean bro will push back against the
tyranny you're talking about a mistake
would all of a sudden be getting into
physical vibrant confrontation you think
that this regime has all of a sudden
sprung into action wait until they get
what they want wait pause for a second
so like the voting rights act is
completely gutted right
so
so and and a new newer version of that
it
got yeted in in the senate because 41
republican senators was like no we're
not going to vote black people allowing
we're not going to vote to allow our
whole that's our whole strategy it's not
even just black people it's literally
like you know making it a national
holiday federal holiday to be able to
vote
like that's in the provision they even
added voter id into it you know what i
mean the democrats are so cowardly that
they were like yeah sure we'll put voter
id in there [ __ ] it who cares and even
then republicans were like nope we're
not doing that and
so so what federal law was charlie even
[ __ ] talking about with respect to
like elections being stolen like what
you just want like uh idaho
uh what like i i just i don't get it
like
what more could they they want is just
the republican state legislatures should
be able to overturn democratic results
if they don't go the way of the
republicans like that's what he's i
guess that's that's kind of what they're
doing they're kind of doing that in
texas like they're allowing the liberty
to stay for uh you know republican
legislatures to be able to do that
so i guess they that's what they want
maybe i don't know well don junior has
the answers uh
shout out to don junior a favorite
forever and always put out a [ __ ] to the
friends of the show shout out good luck
with all of that leftovers
thank you don
guns don't kill people alec baldwin
kills people
um
classy as ever don jr ladies and
gentlemen it can be yours for 28 dollars
wild
you know it's crazy how
this alec baldwin made fun of of trump
and they're literally celebrating a poor
woman who was accidentally murdered on
or killed on on set
uh
it's it's insane it's actually literally
insane
there's a whole bunch of them yeah no
it's like mass shootings happen and you
know republicans are like oh it's fine
it's whatever alec baldwin accidentally
shoots someone and it's like
yeah hey they saying karma like that
woman deserved to die because alcohol
would make fun of his dad
that look when an anti-gun nut kills
more people with a gun than your
extensive firearm collection ever has
yeah fact check true that's donald trump
dude he's such a he's such an epic
poster dude
epic meme sauce man it's great
absolutely
how do we stay in english for [ __ ]
i guess that's a joke about how she
pretended to be uh
spanish or something
let's all watch alec baldwin blame the
gun
i mean quite literally this is an
instance where like
the [ __ ] gun is responsible for it
well it was i think it was the um
it ended up being what you said dan the
pro or the second director or whatever
[ __ ] up the 80 [ __ ] up in the in the
armor who apparently was like a 24 year
old girl who only got the job because of
nepotism because her dad is like a
legendary armor in hollywood oh yeah and
this was her second movie ever and
apparently now it's coming out that even
on her first movie
she like fired off a gun without any
warning uh and almost blew out uh
nicholas cage's eardrum as a result
that's awesome she got a job after that
yeah well what i what i read who's the
guy who the second director or whatever
the first assistant it was the the ad
first ad so the first ad
uh
is supposed to look at the chamber spin
it yeah inspect it but
they didn't do that and they hadn't it
off the gun and said it was uh all clear
and i also read there was 500 uh
live ammunition on set which is pretty
psychotic
yeah yeah i mean there should just never
be live ammunition yeah especially when
blanks look so similar to like regular
ammo yeah it just doesn't have the the
projectile anyway let's look but but
like this woman is the victim and so
it's just pretty
know the difference big pharma big
parma
what like parmesan cheese
i don't get it
no way yeah it must hurt donald trump jr
like
hunter so much if he's got a big old hog
he's got a big hog he did you've seen
his [ __ ]
i saw the picture how did i not see that
it was all over the internet yeah he he
he is a fat [ __ ] uh he has sex with sex
workers he wants them to unionize well
donald trump has sex with uh he he does
he has a weird shaped cog he does the
proletarian cocaine none of that [ __ ]
highbrow [ __ ] he does crack okay
right and
yeah most importantly his dad loves him
like his dad literally joe biden loves
hunter biden okay that's what hurts the
most yeah donald trump does not love
donald trump jr hold on know the
difference big pharma big parma still
not understanding that one big karma
i mean again karma would insinuate that
he died unfortunately you're ignoring
the fact that a woman tragically lost
her life with a family like two days
earlier yeah they don't give a [ __ ] it's
crazy wow lots of lots of big dad memes
guns don't kill people alec baldwin
kills can you imagine wearing that
get yours today how just imagine wearing
that this is a pathetic [ __ ]
he's like a pathetic person i don't know
how he's like sad
he's such a sad pathetic [ __ ] loser
and every moment of his life is pain you
know what i mean
[Laughter]
i mean seriously every [ __ ] moment of
that dude
uh some breaking news i figured you guys
would want to hear about uh the the
announcement is in oh no facebook's
rebrand the new facebook the metaverse
is meta
it's met as [ __ ]
announced 20 minutes ago
they're trying to distance themselves as
much as possible
it's still called facebook though isn't
that just like the parent company i
guess yeah they're it's like the
alphabet yeah the alphabet google shoes
exactly meta
yes because they want to
really lean into the whole uh augmented
reality thing it's not happening yeah
sorry zach
the new meta would be
nobody using facebook that's my perfect
that's a new meta yeah that'd be a great
meta [ __ ] hate facebook and
everything it is
yeah that's um
it's disappointing they should have they
should have gone they should lean into
the patriotism
oh jesus patriot book i mean at this
point it's really just a right-wing
[ __ ] grounds anyway yeah patriot
book
all right let's get to the main story
build back better is falling apart hit
me with that [ __ ]
um
hit me with that regular smegula here we
go
could be better bill
nice
um pretty good biden announced uh you
know we've been working on this 3.5
trillion package that would
revolutionize uh
american working life
two years of free community college paid
family leave prescription drug price
control
universal non means tested child care
plus tax credit
at this point
you're reading everything that's taken
off the bill yeah i know yeah this is
what the good stuff
that we were all looking forward to and
of course the billionaire attacks
remember when everybody was like joe joe
biden's going to be the next fdr like is
joe biden in the next episode is he
better and then on the republican side
they were like joe biden's a communist
he's a communist he's doing chat comp
[ __ ] and it's like
yeah no it was so obvious that it was
never gonna happen he tried
unfortunately no he could have [ __ ]
done weight i mean what could he have
done okay because you have gel mansion
and
kristen cinema
and there's and it's like these
[ __ ] are not moving an inch
first of all they set an unfortunate or
a ridiculous expectation that the bill
was going to pay for itself it was gonna
be a net zero bill
um but they had some good provisions in
there to be able to do that one of them
was uh pharmaceutical price negotiations
medicare was going to be allowed to
negotiate with big pharma when they're
doing mass purchases of pharmaceuticals
and that would greatly reduce the cost
and allow the government to keep like
hundreds of billions of dollars over the
course of 10 years
but of course
you know immediately kirsten cinema and
also secretly bob menendez
uh decided against that and there's
plenty of other senators that were also
against it too because they're in the
[ __ ] pocket of
pharma prescription the government
cannot negotiate the price of
prescription drugs that it buys
millions we're the only country
imagine how cocked we are
in any private sector any public sector
you can negotiate bulk prices you can
negotiate the prices for [ __ ]
strawberries on the side of the road if
you buy enough
you know what i'm saying like
the window is open
but somehow
we are so and also we have the highest
so and you know no prescription drug
companies knowing that we can't
negotiate prices in bulk we have the
most expensive prices in the world too
yeah we are absolutely [ __ ] cocked we
allowed the va to do that recently only
like only recently in the past like five
years is the va allowed to even
negotiate
and um that was fought
against as well like they didn't i would
like to know the rationale i understand
that there's lobbyists and they get
[ __ ] you know all these nice treats
from them
how do they justify publicly voting
against that stephen crowder
does videos on this like what's his
rationale so the rationale behind the
reactionary people to get their talking
points from the american enterprise
institute numerous other think tanks is
that uh america is subsidizing the rest
of the world's uh uh you know lower
pharma prices like we're actually taking
a fat l so that you know we can be as
innovative as possible it's all [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay a lot of that they're
saying we need [ __ ] massive money to
fund research otherwise nobody [ __ ]
we a lot of that is just a publicly
funded or recently pathetic that they
purchase that like big pharma literally
purchases the patents on and the the
novel chemical compounds when you look
at that because that's what you need to
that's at the heart of the matter novel
chemical compound creation right
um when you look at novel chemical
compounds the united states of america
of course
makes the most but that's because it's
one of the [ __ ] largest countries on
the planet right uh and if you look at
it per capita when it comes to like new
novel chemical compound creation united
states is not number one in medical
innovation at all per in a per capita
conversation it barely cracks the top
ten and that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
considering the reality that like the
reason why we have this to begin with
was because uh we're paying 10x the
price for insulin uh in comparison to
canada it's a disgusting [ __ ] freak
show that crowder can actually people
like him can actually go out and argue
that and then people believe it i mean
it's it's sick [ __ ] and the problem
is these people are gonna distab they're
gonna destabilize society
we just can't keep operating like this
where people are
be like these pharma executives are
probably making what billions of dollars
a year and like joe manchin's daughter
who got a 600
raise after she
uh she cranked up the prices of epipen
when she was at milan uh cranked up the
prices of epipen by 400 percent
that's why she got a 600 raised dude
genius i [ __ ] i who could have
thought of that i want to jail all of
these people democrat republican doesn't
[ __ ] matter i want their children to
go to jail i want them to go to jail one
of them to be under the [ __ ] jail it
makes me so angry so you agree with the
guy it's time to use our guns
like
obviously not uh
it's not time to use our guns
uh but violence is a constant in any
political uh
you know violence is literally the
distribution or the distribution of
violence is literally at the heart of
politics so people that say that like
violence is never occurring or you can
have like a truly non-violent movement
or that violence is uh non-existent in
like western democracies are [ __ ]
delusional every time a cop bashes a
protester's skull in that's [ __ ]
state violence
okay you just are conditioned into
thinking that that's normal um
when someone
kicks uh when someone throws a tear gas
canister at protesters when cops do that
that's not violence when you use a leaf
blower to blow back that tear gas at the
cops that's considered violence
yeah one side doesn't get prosecuted for
it the other side does but that's a
it's like different it's just
competition it's just
it's just it's just sad bro
you know like
we just want to negotiate the price so
that we're not spending over over
spending hundreds of billions of dollars
into literally just to enrich like a few
handful of rich executives yeah well
it's not just if you have rich
executives they're all publicly traded
uh
stocks so a lot of these companies are
like enriching the top 10 percent of
wealth in the united states
95 of the stock market is owned by like
the top uh
half a percent of people that's what i
was talking about no not 95 but the top
10 of wealth in the united states of
america own 85 of the stock market so
they realize all of the benefits of the
stock market other people have like you
know a 401k if at that yeah and they go
what about your 401k it's like yeah i
mean that's it you make a lot more money
just from having good benefits and
social security and as always when the
stock market is doing well it does not
trickle downward it's uh it's just only
trickling upwards it's it's centralized
at the top
yeah but if it does poorly then you're
[ __ ] because the losses are always
socialized whereas the those guys always
get out too yeah guys at top you know
who are savvy
you know what the [ __ ] they're doing
insider trading and it's disgusting and
and you know there's so many different
parts of this there's so many different
components of this infrastructure bill
it's bad politically to like uh have
this like super long and convoluted
process similar thing happened uh in the
aca negotiations under obamacare under
obama where obama had 60 democrats in
the senate and even then there was some
people that were spoiling it you know
what i mean and that's why we couldn't
get the public option and they
negotiated basically against themselves
for no [ __ ] reason whatsoever and
watered down
the aca which is originally a heritage
uh
foundation uh uh policy that was first
implemented by mitt romney in
massachusetts so like you know even the
[ __ ] program that they brought
forward as obamacare which helped a lot
of people certainly and had really
popular provisions in it
uh like the pre-existing condition
coverage and all that
um
that was still a right-wing answer to
socialized medicine that you know 10
years later 20 years later democrats
were championing that republicans
immediately were against so
it's really [ __ ] up and the exact same
thing is happening here with the
infrastructure bill uh we're selling it
as infrastructure this is not really
infrastructure it's human infrastructure
that's what they're calling it so
because they want to market it to the
hogs
and it's necessary stuff medicare
eligibility lowered to 55 not happening
you know all of these all these
provisions for child care child care tax
credits incredibly popular seventy
percent of the country wants it dude it
would pull 50
of
poverty-stricken children out of poverty
yeah immediately
and that number is like 12 million if
i'm not mistaken it's horrific
and um you know commit free community
college which would be just an
incredible boon for
especially you know poor working-class
people so once you do two years of
community college you can get into a
university pretty easily
and um
as we talked about before paid family
leave which joe rogan uh
uh only betas want that so that's not
yeah that was that was supposed to be
that was supposed to be uh 12 weeks
originally
that was negotiated down to four weeks
and then now it's an opt-in program that
workers have to pay for out of pocket if
they want to even do it what's the point
so like it's not even coming out of the
government budget there's no subsidies
offered to it so yeah now we've said no
paid family leave no tuition free
community college no meaningful climate
provisions because that was immediately
the climate permission was really
interesting by the way it was really
cool
they were incentivizing companies
uh power companies to convert to green
energy which they're doing already by
the way they're doing it about two
percent a year they wanted them to do it
at four percent a year and if they were
able to hit the four percent goal they
were going to pay them a bunch of money
but the interesting part was that they
were going to punish companies that
didn't make that change by charging them
money
uh it seemed like a fantastic program
that uh was completely struck and down
no no carbon tax even like which is like
the market
no most neoliberal uh uh [ __ ]
argument for for
climate change is just like you can't
even do that it's crazy so they're
saying that no vision hearing dental
prescriptions no vision hearing dental
for medicare no medicare eligibility
lowered uh again 90 90 approval rating
for lowering the medicare eligibility
down to 55. okay we're not talking about
medicare for all we're just improving
the pool of people that are covered by
medicare which which ultimately is less
costly for the government in the long
term you think so because that's really
expensive medicare to lower it from 65
to 55. yeah it's it well well so how do
you pay for that
you pay for it by taxing people um we
don't believe in that here exactly and
and um
no vision hearing dental coverage again
incredibly popular these are voters by
the way these are [ __ ] voters voters
want this the people that actually vote
are old people i would love
that vision and dental is not considered
necessary medical [ __ ] for old people
vision hearing and mental illness
yeah awesome um vision and dental and
hearing is not
what is what the [ __ ] is now they have
means-tested child care it's not
universal anymore so now if you uh
instead of making 60 000 if you make
like 65 000 in in [ __ ] new jersey or
in a place that's like a more expensive
you're no longer eligible for child care
that sucks
that's such [ __ ] that means tested
programs like that also develop a lot of
anxiety and a lot of frustration among
the working class because then they're
like well i'm paying for it i think oh
my god but i'm not getting any of that
well they're getting it what the [ __ ]
yeah and i mean if you know how
expensive child care is like a thousand
dollars a month you know for one kid
that's like a reasonable price that's
not a super expensive one so
yeah you know if you have two kids
you're looking at twenty thousand
dollars a year easily if you're making
sixty thousand sixty five thousand
dollars uh you're [ __ ] basically yeah
i think the progressive should uh vote
no for this like i think the progressive
should destroy this bill
yeah 100 because this bill sucks well
what's the benefit of destroying the
bill when you say no when you actually
ever say no and progressives
unfortunately are too kind and too like
like they they actually operate from a
morality point of view and if you're
like thinking about this from a morality
point of view obviously the best thing
to do is harm reduction no matter what
you can get right
so
um so knowing that
uh and also knowing the reality that
like if you do stand against this bill
you will get [ __ ] destroyed by the
media in a way that joe manchin and
kirsten cinema or the rotating villain
as they call it in the democratic party
will never get destroyed
um
they're they're fearful of like standing
against it and truly saying i don't want
this bill now about what is it what's
the benefit of just saying [ __ ] this no
like who does that because next time
around when there's another negotiation
your side which has more numbers by the
way technically supposedly the
progressive caucus is much larger than
the six congress persons or six
representatives and that works
against it oh i mean
when it doesn't will there be a next
time well there's always the next time
they have to pass legislation so but
like the next time it's going to be
stacked republican after the midterm and
probably even the president well even
this passes this passes still stacked
republican this doesn't pass still
stacked republican the only way that we
don't the only way that there's like a
serious recovery for the biden
administration is if he like either
federalizes or
decriminalizes marijuana at the federal
level or just does a massive
buy executive action and he has the
legal uh uh he has a legal uh
circumstances to do this like he has the
legal power to do this uh abolish a
student loan debt
like something major before the midterms
other than that he's [ __ ] dude we are
[ __ ] yeah republicans are coming no
matter what like
no matter who's passing or doesn't pass
yeah so the the one of my favorite
things besides so basically the two is
more [ __ ] up in my opinion
prescription drug prices the fact that
we can't all agree to [ __ ] these douche
[ __ ] evil pieces of [ __ ] and
negotiate down life-saving drugs like
insulin the other one is the billionaire
tax shut down by joe manchin
attacks on 700 people
who are basically paying zero percent
these people pay zero percent tax on
their money uh
for the record for those of you who
don't understand this concept
um they billionaires and and
millionaires um
ceos especially like they don't make
their money off of income in the same
way that like the average citizen does
or even people like myself do like
i get paid off amazon
and that's my yearly income that gets
taxed by the government at the end of
the year these guys actually get stocks
so they get paid in like stock options
and what that means is you can park
your assets
and your wealth in its entirety in the
stock market
and you can even show losses as a matter
of fact if you would like to
um and if you ever need money well you
have endless amounts of leverage because
you
they look at like how what your stock
portfolio looks like and you're a
multi-billionaire
you can literally go to a bank and be
like i want to borrow against my endless
amount of leverage
and they even give you like super low
interest rates awesome super low
interest rate loans and you [ __ ] buy
borrow die that's what they end up
paying the bank
more
at interest by far than they pay the
government yeah [ __ ] taxes so the
banks are essentially collecting any
small amount of tax
that the government should be getting
yeah yeah so i mean and this is not even
a loophole i would say this is literally
the way that the system is designed so
going against that and saying like no
actually you should be forced to
liquidate some of your assets if you
can't pay a certain percentage of your
like year over year
uh uh like net revenue gain or your
wealth gain
um
and people were very frustrated by there
were so many people in my uh in my
replies being like uh well these are
unrealized at like these are yeah you
know this is unrealized wealth in the
stock market like that sets a really
scary present it's like no it doesn't it
literally does not you're [ __ ] psycho
first of all you're not in the top 700
people of wealth so this does not
concern you shut the [ __ ] up
but secondly
uh you do that already like you have a
house okay if you have a house if you
have bought a house
there are people that come look at the
[ __ ] property value of your house
and they tax you on it not in california
by the way but most states have uh
appreciation
yeah facts but like but here's the thing
they do that they could have like quants
and [ __ ] mathematicians like standing
at the irs and literally uh looking at
like calculating what your what your
gains look like in the stuff that
happens i was reading about p a lot of
people like
in washington where the real estate
prices are going up because you know the
property value's going up a lot and
people who've been living in their house
for 30 40 years are basically being
forced to sell their home because they
can't afford the property tax because it
goes up every year and so if that
person's got to deal with it here's the
thing also there was a provision in the
billionaire income tax
that allows you to write off losses as
well so there is a mechanism
that's that you know because it's it's
kind of [ __ ] up to be like okay
let's say elon musk
is worth 200 billion dollars
because the stock market had a crazy
year
so he's got to pay what like 20 billion
dollars in tax or something and then the
next year the tr the stock goes to half
and now he's only worth a hundred
billion dollars i hope
you're praying for the downfall dude i
should be you just want bad things to
happen to him oh my god it's not even
bad things i just want like
it's not a normal stock market anyway go
on yeah so so if the next year his
company's worth 100 billion and [ __ ]
like that does happen especially with a
company like tesla
uh
then
it's there is a strange area there where
it's like
all of a sudden he paid 20 billion
dollars in tax
and now his company is worth a hundred
billion
or now he's worth a hundred billion
it's it is it is a strange kind of
inexplicable
gray zone there but if you can write it
off i guess that gives you some leeway
yeah
not only that but also what is deeply
frustrating about this concept is that
we have regressive taxes right we have
plenty of regressive taxes sales tax is
a great example of this a regressive tax
uh taxes the working poor or the working
class more than it taxes wealthy people
like it hits them harder right
you never have like a tv show this is
what david dane was saying from the
american prospect you never have like a
[ __ ] news show where we're talking
about like a new sales tax where it's
like up next we're going to hear from
the janitor uh that is gonna talk about
how this uh new sales tax is hurting his
productivity and like
because
the reason why we don't hear about that
is because like one we understand that
like of course taxes are necessary to
you know build roads and whatnot and
infrastructure
and the other reason is because we don't
hear from the janitor because the
janitor doesn't own the [ __ ] media
company the people who own the media
company on the other hand are the ones
who are like yeah [ __ ] no we are not
doing this
and i don't know if you pulled up the
mitt romney video but yeah i really love
this like counter argument that mitt
romney put forward so just a little
background though so for example jeff
bezos salaries eighty thousand dollars
so he takes out loans on a stock and he
essentially pays no income tax
the the law would apply to people
earning over a hundred million dollars a
year
yeah or households that are worth one
billion dollars in assets for three
years reply to about 700 people
it works by taxing unrealized gains for
example if jeff bezos has 10 billion in
amazon stock over a year
and it becomes 11 billion
the 11 billion dollar would be taxed at
around 20 so even by
that
it's even less it
if it was 10 billion and it raised to 11
billion it would be a one billion dollar
gain and yeah so that gain is what would
be tax yeah that's what i yeah i thought
i wrote 11.
right so so right so 1 billion would be
taxed at 20 which by the way i pay 50
income tax that's the thing that's like
really way [ __ ] less already than
most people are paying yeah that's the
thing is really frustrating it's not
just you either like when you look at
like i mean look hi it wasn't that long
ago when i was making you know 60 000 a
year in the state of california and like
when you're doing that
the percentage of like your your
revenue that you have generated your net
revenue that you've generated over the
year without like thinking about your
you know things that you're paying for
like your housing and all this stuff
like the percentage of the entire genera
uh revenue that you've generated that is
taxed is gigantic in comparison to a
[ __ ] billionaire when you look at
that
that's like billionaires are paying like
0.001 percent whereas most people like
most average americans are paying like
a larger [ __ ] chunk of their like
overall these people
so for example
just uh the 10 billionaire the 10
richest billionaires alone
if this tax was applied to them would
generate nearly 300 billion dollars per
year
10
10 people yeah would generate 300 you
know what you could do with 300 billion
dollars a year and that's just 10 you
know we're talking about 700 percentage
of our military budget i mean holy [ __ ]
yeah and so you know more guns that's
like at least 10 uh [ __ ] f-14s yeah
well yeah depending on yeah yeah
not a f-35 though them shits are
expensive oh maybe two of those yeah
yeah that makes a difference i'm telling
you
um there was a billionaire that was very
upset about this and and very publicly
so
yeah so elon musk wait yeah you want to
segue into that though elon musk has
been uh vocal against this poor
billionaires
uh let me see here
uh this uh
economist projected that musk would owe
up to
50 billion in taxes during the first
five-year stretch and daddy bezos would
owe 44 billion
elon musk is not happy about this and
he'd still be the richest man in america
by the way well of course who else i
mean in the world sorry not in america
daddy daddy elon but having a good run
yeah so here this guy says for u.s
citizens opposed to the unrealized
capital gains tax proposal by senator
ron wyden here's an example of a tactful
and diplomatic letter template i made
you can use it to
by the way he tags them cc daddy bezos
and elon musk please please daddy yeah
so these [ __ ] boot licking sims i
mean he's like he is a ceo himself so
he's at least a little bit closer to
becoming a billionaire maybe than than
others so so
imagine these guys want working-class
people to lobby their congress members
to not raise taxes on 700 billionaires
listen to this [ __ ] i expect you to
oppose a widens proposal to tax
unrealized capital gains although the
proposal targets billionaires and not
myself the government of elected
representatives have a track record of
scope creep i don't know if that's
actually a thing
i mean i know what he means he's saying
a fancy way of saying slippery slope
which is a fallacy but
uh so a scope creep when writing new
taxes he's like he's like you guys are
not doing taxes for me but like
you know maybe you could and that's
scary you could be taxing my unreal the
working class unrealized gains yeah dude
totally well that they do they do it's
called the capital gains tax they
already do that because the working
class cannot park all of their hold on
capital gains is when you sell the stock
though exactly but that's what i'm
saying that's not unrealized gains
not
but like you know what i mean they
already tax the working classes yeah we
pay fully you pay money when you try to
take that money out these [ __ ]
don't ever take it out in fact yeah the
whole idea is to die with the debt so
that they're even then their inheritors
don't ever have to pay buy borrow die
that's how it [ __ ] works but the
reason why i said that is because like
the working class already does get taxed
on the [ __ ] stock market movements
like they already do that because they
don't have the [ __ ] well my endless
sea of the joke being that uh the fact
that this guy thinks that first they
came for the 700 billionaires and then
next they came for my for your untap
it's like dude no
i anticipate that any new unrealized
capital gains tax will slowly make their
way down to the middle class retirement
investments
uh over the next several years it will
start with the billionaires and then
it's always like they came for the jews
first and they didn't say anything yeah
then they came for the blacks and they
didn't say anything
next they came for me and there was no
billionaires left to speak for me
and eventually millionaires then the
modest investments will get hit possibly
within a decade although principal
residents and holdings in 401k plans
apparently will be excluded the wyden
proposal takes new tax hikes a step
closer to imposing unrealized capital
gains tax on average investors like shut
the [ __ ] up that's not what's going on
[ __ ] yeah exactly i hate this i hate
this jail this person throw him in jail
i mean get the guns you post like this
you throw them in jail okay i sort of
you know it's like sure you can you can
have any fantasy you want it's like uh
you know
dude dude
i mean this is the argument and it
[ __ ] works this is not a real
argument that's not what's happening i
know this law is literally about taxing
billionaires you know it's like oh
it's it's insane i mean it's it really
strikes at that uh
very common uh mark twain quote is that
every
american uh just sees themselves as time
temporarily
it was steinbeck are you sure yeah
uh and even then it wasn't actually
steinbeck it was just like
misattributed to steinbeck most famously
yeah it's uh socialism will never work
in the united states of america because
the working class do not see themselves
as an exploited proletariat but
temporarily embarrassed millionaires
yeah exactly which is such a cliche but
i mean you see it every day yeah and
[ __ ] like this and another and like how
were you not pissed the [ __ ] off that
working class people like okay i'm rich
right i pay 50 taxes if these
[ __ ] these 700 guys were paying
50 taxes on their income and we'd be all
good yeah well not income technically
you don't understand these are not
liquid right these are just simply
assets you're punishing someone for
being 100 million they don't have 100
billion dollars in the bank account what
do you understand it's just that's how
taxes work i just i hate that like the
concept itself literally is like
different for billionaires like we act
like
if you if you could not pay your taxes
right now
okay you get hit with a bill at the end
of the year okay you would have to
liquidate some of your [ __ ] assets to
pay your taxes okay but when it's uh
yeah liquidate some of your stocks
exactly
[ __ ] billionaires i spent all that
yeah it's like the irs being like are
you always a million dollars like sorry
bro i bought a bunch of cars yeah it's
like
[ __ ] dude um what are we gonna do oh no
they want to get [ __ ] cars and pay
your tax yeah listen i i may not be a
smart man but i know that billionaires
should be paying more than like
literally zero elon musk in like 2008
paid zero dollars anyway here's elon
musk's uh response to this beaut this
guy's literally boot licking him yeah i
mean first of all it is kind of cool
that he was able to write with an entire
boot down his [ __ ] throat like i
don't know how he's breathing let alone
typing that [ __ ] letter to a
congressperson but elon uh
saw the simp signal and responded
exactly eventually they run out of other
people's money and then they come for
you let's worry about that after we get
your money why are they why are they
running out of money maybe it's because
they're subsidizing your [ __ ]
[ __ ] company that makes exploding
vehicles that's what [ __ ] it makes me
so mad about elon musk is it like he
literally would not be a person without
the government teat okay which i don't
even have a [ __ ] problem with
especially if you're subsidizing like
green energy initiatives and whatnot but
like elon musk
has always taken advantage of ev credits
he's always taken advantage of of of uh
like spacex itself is literally a uh
otherwise publicly funded [ __ ] uh
publicly funded institution this
argument that that is now privatized by
elon musk it doesn't make sense listen
to this he says
when they run out of other people's
money
then they come for you that implies that
we have any of your money we have none
of your money the government gets none
of your money and then we
literally
subsidizing his business we are as
taxpayers subsidizing his
um
monzi
team
allegedly uh we're short on time dan no
i was going to say it's not literally
zero percent it's it's three percent
well that that was in the last year but
there was a year in 2018. in 2018 he
paid zero federal income tax and but
between 2014
and 18
uh his true tax rate was 3.2 yeah i paid
50 yep yeah uh here's more
uh elon musk is such a [ __ ] douchebag
man and not only this you know he really
[ __ ] pissed me off with the kovid
[ __ ] he was on twitter telling people
not to worry about it
yeah he says he'll be done by april well
he was real [ __ ] quiet now seven
hundred thousand americans uh dead no he
i mean don't don't go to him he'll he
won't shut the [ __ ] up he will he will
start talking again because like there's
no accountability he has a [ __ ] army
of stains like you know whole ass adults
that like think you know we're going to
the moon every time we [ __ ] post
something it's like sheba ela on elon
you know my my sheba is [ __ ] i mean i
don't know how to describe it it's like
this is your oppressor
anyway he says uh
this is my favorite according so
brilliant by the way
here's another elon one the u.s federal
debt gdp was 56
and 2000 now it's 126 and climb
what was why were we spending so much
money what what happened since 2000
numerous times well there was another
2008 too this is so stupid we [ __ ]
control the entire planet's uh uh
currency dude
yeah now here he's complaining about
keep going out here just send me the
link so i can navigate or here it is
i've got it here dude i love that he
starts talking about the national debt
it's like dude first of all your entire
business relies on the government
subsidized hold on let's go in order
here according to their own estimate
this tax only covers 10 of the 3.5
trillion spending bill where does the
other 90 come from the answer is you
okay well even if not true let's first
of all let's just say it's true i still
want the government like i want the
[ __ ] 350 billion
who cares
yeah it's fair let's say it's true the
answer is you okay fine i still want
your 350 billion
i mean it's it's again it's [ __ ] fair
dude i don't understand they live here
they use the infrastructure we make
their incredible businesses possible do
these guys really think they're entitled
to pay zero taxes they pay nothing
nothing
yeah i mean they do think that they're
entitled to pay zero taxes because
they're productive and they're job
creators and you should be grateful
every single day that elon musk is here
and a lot of people unironically believe
that [ __ ] i'm gonna be honest with
you okay and i this is like a way that i
explain the concept to my friends it's
like elon musk jeff bezos these people
these billionaires
they are like demigods they're kings
right
and in prior
uh ways that uh organized society we had
theocratic monarchies and the peasant
class justified the existence of the
theocratic monarch
because they said well god put him in
that position of power when it's
obviously not the case now under
capitalism these people have exactly the
same level of [ __ ] power okay they
have the exact same level of power
there's the exact same wealth disparity
that exists between the peasant class
and you know the monarchs right
and now our justification for it is
meritocracy this lie that we've told
people that like under a capitalist
organization of the economy if you're
[ __ ] elon musk that's not because you
like [ __ ] enough people to get to the
top in the way that elon musk did but
actually because he deserves to be there
because he's the hardest worker and he
works you know three billion times
harder than the average american
and and uh you know he he he deserves it
he deserves all of that listen
i'm not opposed to the whole notion of
meritocracy but that doesn't exclude
someone from [ __ ] having to pay taxes
no
look hard work is important but like
probability is still a major factor in
the way that these people become the as
successful as they are
so in a situation where uh there is no
true equality of opportunity there is
none in america there is no equality of
opportunity
especially true if you look at it
universally especially true if you look
at it worldwide there's no [ __ ]
equality of opportunity if you're born
in bangladesh you know what i mean like
where's the equality opportunity there
it doesn't exist so because there's so
much probability i think governments
internationally
should provide at least a base level of
material support as best as they can to
ensure that like you at least get
education shelter if you need it food if
you need it you know what i mean clothes
on your [ __ ] back
and an opportunity true opportunity to
have a meaningful existence where you
maximize your productivity
creativity elon can tell himself
whatever the [ __ ] you want i'm just
saying he needs to pay his [ __ ] taxes
this piece of [ __ ]
all right yeah
going down
u.s national debt
is uh 29 billion
or uh 230 000 per taxpayer even if
taxing all billionaires at 100 would
make only a small dent
in that number
so obviously the mess the rest must come
from the general public this is basic
math how does a ceo who engages in buy
borrow die not understand the concept of
debt and and like how nobody's saying
pay off the whole history of the net of
the national debt we just want you to
pay some [ __ ] taxes bro yeah and
that's it
the the national debt the percentage
that is like uh you know chinese owned
is like four percent yeah it's all owned
by america yeah it's still owned by
americans so like you shut the [ __ ] up
this doesn't who gives a [ __ ] also you
want to know you want to know how you
tackle the debt by [ __ ] taxi
billionaires yeah by taxing people who
don't pay taxes you know why
because
it's
dude this is so [ __ ] by the way he's
linking
this is so stupid bro what are you doing
about the debt
you're saying that me giving you all my
money would make a small dent so i'm not
even going to give you uh any of my
money no i love that i love all of these
you know what's funny about all of these
[ __ ] uh websites the us debt clock or
like you know these debt watch uh budget
hawks these deficit hawks
they rarely ever talk about defense
spending like they'll put it in there
this is a [ __ ] nightmare they'll
[ __ ] put it in there but they're like
yeah you know that's like discretionary
spending it's not a big deal come on
let's not talk about that
this is where he linked there's a mobile
app dude if you wanna if you want to be
a [ __ ] pathetic loser mobile app yeah
and i mean the whole notion of of debt
is like
such a [ __ ] stupid concept because
again like you said that
these [ __ ] know about that debt
isn't such a bad thing all the time
because sometimes you can get money buy
[ __ ] and make more money with that money
like when you invest in infrastructure
and jobs and [ __ ] like that right when
you wasted bombing [ __ ] uh yeah
civilians in iraq yeah it's probably a
not a good investment back in 2015 uh la
times wrote an article about elon musk's
growing empire being fueled by 4.9
billion in government subsidies so
that's where the government is spending
their [ __ ] uh money on elon so what
the [ __ ] are you talking about the only
reason why you have a business is the
[ __ ] american government holy [ __ ] so
that's that's one aspect of this that's
like additionally hypocritical and
hilarious uh and then also the other
side of it is just like how laughably
unaware he is or i guess he's being
deliberately obtuse here yeah where he
talks about like the us national debt
and like paying off of it in its
entirety and not only that but also like
um
you know uh
refusing to
refusing to examine that like taxes are
a necessity is he like [ __ ] zero is
he like a zero tax guy is he a
libertarian yeah it's [ __ ] pathetic
it's like that he's trying to drum up
fear of working-class people having to
pay taxes
it's [ __ ] pathetic dude yeah i used
to like this guy man it's just straight
reactionary [ __ ] this is a
republican so
in 2015 uh elon paid 68 000 in federal
income tax in 2017
he paid 65
000. 2018 he paid zero dollars
in federal income tax between 2014 and
18 he had a true tax rate of 3.27
percent
so
yeah spending is the real problem yeah
we should just cut all the [ __ ]
subsidies
hey guys guys it wouldn't make that big
of a difference if i was paying taxes
come on
yeah
and also yeah but you're right is he
saying nobody paid taxes because uh that
might be a problem for you buddy yeah
exactly
joe manchin who shot down the
billionaire tax gave this rationale
i know we're short on time but uh
this is all good stuff here guys
um
this is the democrat
i don't like it i
i don't like the connotation that we're
targeting different people
there's people that basically i don't
like solving different
unless they're iraqis with a dome strike
well he doesn't like targeting different
people it's like dog that's how taxes
work yeah exactly what the [ __ ] they're
just describing the concept of taxes and
being like this is a scary thing it's
like no [ __ ] you target people
who are avoiding taxes okay
targeting the people i like to just have
i just like to throw [ __ ] out there and
see what happens zero constituents of
joe manchin are billionaires by the way
no millionaires in west virginia 30 of
west virginians actually uh uh are on
welfare
that's just what i don't get i just
don't [ __ ] understand
it's just it's such a fraud this whole
thing is such a fraud our elected
officials are representing 700 people
while the rest while the rest of the
vast majority of the rest of america
can't pay for [ __ ] child care can't
pay full health insurance
is
very poor and it's just such a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
it's nice there's people that basically
they've contributed to society and
create a lot of jobs
they don't have to pay taxes
yeah sure yeah that's
another way to [ __ ] you know
do some nice little tax avoidance uh by
by using a 501c3 you know bill gates
like good guy you know he uses all of
his put all of his assets in
philanthropy his [ __ ] net worth grew
uh from 30 billion to 100 billion by the
way yeah elon musk recently on the same
day he made that tweet made the most
money in a single day of 35
and the history of humanity made 35
billion dollars in one day after hertz
decided to buy a bunch of teslas and the
stock jumped up yeah on the same day
normal stock market by the way normal
stock market where 35 billion in one day
yeah you you you're [ __ ] a single
person's uh wealth grows by 35 billion
dollars and the same [ __ ] day he went
to twitter to [ __ ] about taxes yeah
here by the way covet hit us pretty hard
right hit most was pretty hard mark
zuckerberg uh looks like he
double or quadrupled his net value bill
gates uh this [ __ ] doesn't even
work anymore he's been retired yeah he's
philanthropy all that's going to flame
yeah thank god for a philanthropist that
dude makes a lot of money yeah again he
went from 33 billion he i think he had
like 33 billion when he decided to
launch the bill and melinda gates
foundation and now he has 124 billion
that's crazy he's not giving out money
fast enough
yeah he needs to give money out fast he
gets to give money away faster he's
making too much money
man
150 million dollar spending is pretty
wow
such a good guy
what have you done nothing right exactly
150 million dollars is point four
percent of how much he made in one day
from that hurt sale people would say
well 150 is better than nothing a lot of
people would say yeah why are you
[ __ ] on a donation shaming donation
yeah because it's not about the [ __ ]
donation charity and philanthropy
demonstrably has not [ __ ] solved all
the problems that we currently
experience
in the current organization of the
[ __ ] economy you're saying instead
it's crazy how elon musk can buy like a
good headline for 150 million when
technically he should be owing the
government like 50 billion dollars in
taxes yes but because we're all [ __ ]
so we all sim for elon like he's such a
good guy he gave 150 million no he
ripped us all off and then he and then
they turn around and they're like how
much have you donated what the [ __ ] you
have a lot more per capita than him yeah
but it doesn't even [ __ ] matter a lot
more per capita than him because that
doesn't solve the problem the problem is
literally tax avoidance is built into
the tax code for billionaires and
millionaires and corporation owners to
be able to just [ __ ] avoid and skirt
all of these uh all of the same
percentage of taxes that like most
normal people pay yeah so uh here's
everyone here's how all these guys did
in kovit elon musk crushed it was like
at times five bezos crushed it
you know so all these guys are having
the time of their life
um
most of these billionaires actually 50
or more net uh increased their net worth
in uh
the last year it's just fair dude that's
that's the only way to look at this is
like it's it's unfair that they
uh are not subjected to the same
uh same like percentages of like true
taxing bro listen i'm not opposed to
raising taxes on myself i pay 50 tax i
think that's a lot if if we decide i
need more i need more but until these
[ __ ] are paying what i'm paying
then i don't know why like what what are
we doing raising taxes on people like me
and the middle class well whatever i i
can afford to pay more taxes but it just
it's like you're avoiding the real
[ __ ] problem me paying more taxes is
not gonna do anything when you can be
making three hundred billion dollars a
year getting twenty percent
from ten people that's one
number is from ten people yeah from ten
people [ __ ] insane doesn't make any
sense it's it's so [ __ ] gross and so
insane i don't have a problem with like
[ __ ] raising the tops i don't give a
top marginal tax rate
i uh but i but it blows my [ __ ] mind
it blows my mind at like this level of
wealth disparity is literally
manufactured and yet people don't get
upset at it well some do but they don't
get upset at it enough and then they
forget about it and then they get mad at
like other people they're like oh well
[ __ ] you i'm sure there'll be plenty of
comments saying you're not gonna be mad
through rich guys talking about [ __ ]
more rich people paying taxes it's like
i don't care you can [ __ ] tax me more
too okay uh i'm i'm an advocate for that
tax them the same as me and then raise
all of our taxes well if they tax them
the same as you [ __ ] then there'd be
no jobs left there would be no problem
that's what i'm saying everybody if
these guys paid 50 percent then i'll cut
we'd be living in a utopia our flights
would be our cars will be flying
and uh the thing that the thing i've had
i've had robot uh vr sex machines yeah
the thing that is like also something
that people forget is that like the top
marginal tax rate was [ __ ] higher
before donald trump and the very same
people like kirsten and cinema have
literally voted against that when they
weren't in a position of power but when
she is actually in a [ __ ] seat of
power she's like no [ __ ] no of course
i'm not going to weirdo increase the
corporate tax rate that would destroy
the economy yeah the economy is going to
go up and destroyed we're way over time
i could talk about this for
seven hours this [ __ ] is like um it's
gonna ruin our country
it might even happen
it might even ruin civilization as well
it has already that's why there's so
much and it's like we have this chance
now
tax the billionaires and it's
self-defeating these billionaires are
not gonna they're not gonna [ __ ]
unless it ends up like a fallout
situation where they have their own you
know secret organizations and stuff it
might be like that i don't know i got
thoughts on that too someone's gotta
[ __ ] run the bunker you know what i'm
saying
it's not going to be [ __ ] jeffrey's
wiping it 100 billion toilets 100
billion dollars ain't going to mean [ __ ]
and uh when there's 20 people living
underground in bunker that's true
i mean paper money you listen even in
fallout they use they use uh bottle caps
as currency that currency you wipe your
ass with tunnel snakes are coming for
you jeff bezos that's right rad roaches
baby
all right thanks for watching everybody
the war the civil war starts now and
remember that's we have that second
amendment for a reason boys that's right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]